she'll you mentioned in a prior
interview about the late Tim
Hetherington of Restrepo and other
journalists who have lost their lives on
assignment how many times a day a week
did it cross your mind that the same
thing could happen to you you know
you're trying to I've been a
photojournalist for a very long time and
you kind of try not to think about it
while you're always thinking how to stay
safe this film was definitely taking a
risk you know the decision going down
there is that we're gonna make a drug
war film that's not gonna be experts
it's not gonna be talking heads that's
gonna put you in the front row and
really make you feel not learn but
really feel what it feels like to be in
horrors to be in this reality to be in
the midst of it so sure we had a couple
of bad runs and I've had colleagues
including Tim Heatherton that have died
but I think you kind of you know you
really concentrate on on being careful
and I'm pushing and doing what you want
and you kind of block out at the same
time this wow this could be over like
that and that was that was kind of the
balance that we struck we ended up going
to Mars more than 20 times we always
stayed for a very short time we had our
little systems in place it was a very
small two-man crew we tried to not be
visible we try to not step on any wrong
toes not open stuff we shouldn't
question crossed your mind why make a
film if it may be my last time no
because and I think that that was
actually Tim's having 10 message to me
like he didn't know where he didn't he
barely knew Libya but you never know
when it's gonna happen if it does and if
you always think that way then US
photojournalist filmmakers I really go
to the front lines will never do any of
it because if you live in fear then it's
possible anywhere I could step outside
and something would happen so you gotta
actually gotta push everybody has their
own destiny